Speaker 1: The vaccines work so well and enough
people have gotten them that the CDC has announced
no more outdoor masks in most situations for
vaccinated people.
Now, if that sounds underwhelming or if your
reaction is, you know, most a lot of the country's
already been doing that.
These guidelines, of course, are for people
who are following CDC guidelines.
If you've not been following them all along,
then you don't really care what the CDC says.
You're probably not getting vaccinated either.
You're probably you probably have been letting
it rip.
But for those of us who care what the CDC
says and who have been following Joe Biden's
agreement with CDC guidelines.
Remember, these aren't Biden's guidelines.
They are just Joe Biden saying, I will listen
to what the health experts say.
The CDC yesterday announced that outdoor mask
wearing really is not necessary in most situations.
Now, it's very carefully written Americans
who are fully vaccinated, meaning two weeks
after your last dose, whether it's one dose
or two doses, two weeks after the last dose,
at least actually with Jay, maybe longer.
If you're fully vaccinated against coronavirus,
you no longer need to wear a mask outdoors
while walking, running, hiking, biking alone
or in a small group, including with members
of your own household masks are still necessary
in crowded outdoor venues like sports stadiums.
That's what the CDC has said.
Joe Biden coming out and announcing the same
thing.
The CDC stopped short of saying if you're
vaccinated, you just never need a mask outdoors.
They say that it's still conceivably possible
that you could transmit coronavirus and that
with unknown vaccination levels in crowds,
it's safer to wear a mask even if vaccinated
in a big crowd.
Now, I think this makes perfect sense.
Unfortunately, there are some doom and gloom
ers who are furious.
And we were live streaming.
Joe Biden announcing this yesterday.
And I heard people saying, David, you can
still pass it even if vaccinated.
Well, yes, you can, but transmission is reduced
by more than 90 percent.
And outdoors it's almost zero.
Pre vaccination, Dr. Asheesh job leaves.
One out of a thousand cases were transmitted
outdoors.
That's before anyone was vaccinated.
You were really talking about percentages
and a risk level that is lower than the flu
when you're talking about an increasingly
vaccinated outdoor situation.
I've been following the guidelines.
So even though from the beginning I thought
if I'm biking on the bike path, I don't need
a mask.
But after getting some dirty looks, yes, the
judgment worked on me and I put the mask on
when biking or when running or whatever.
We are now being told very clearly by the
CDC that certainly at least vaccinated people
do not need to do that.
Now, the CDC director, Rochelle Walensky,
emphasized a bigger interpretation than the
narrow wording of the CDC, saying, quote,
We no longer feel that the vaccinated people
require masks outdoors other than large public
venues, period.
And one really interesting thing is that the
CDC has also put out a sort of pictograph
that shows a list of activities, the risk
level if you are unvaccinated and the risk
level if you are fully vaccinated.
The risk level for fully vaccinated people
is color coded green, meaning low risk for
every activity, including going to crowded
outdoor events.
The venue and the recommendation may still
be to put a mask on in that situation, even
if vaccinated.
But the CDC making clear if you're vaccinated,
the risk level for a big concert is low.
The risk level for going inside at restaurants
is still low.
Now, of course, it will continue to be lower
as more and more people are vaccinated.
If you individually have a higher risk profile,
then that may not be something you want to
do right away.
And we're going to talk about that later in
my segment about Joe Rogan's recent comments.
But hopefully the point here is that hopefully
this will encourage more people to want to
get vaccinated.
That is increasingly an issue that we are
dealing with in the United States.
While many countries are still having major
supply issues with vaccines in the US, increasingly
the problem is lack of demand.
It's it's actually tragic.
So many countries desperate to get vaccines,
they haven't yet been able to get in the US,
more and more states are going to just show
up.
You don't even need an appointment and they're
still not.
Filling every slot, so hopefully the word
from the CDC and Biden that the masks can
come off for vaccinated people in almost every
scenario will encourage more people to want
to get vaccinated.
The counter point is, if you still don't want
to get vaccinated, you probably don't care
what the CDC says about masks.
And that certainly is a source of concern.
Let's now talk about some of the reaction
from the media to Joe Biden's announcement
of what the CDC has determined regarding masks.